taking responsibility for that aspect of
your life
is freeing because it doesn't make you
feel
well it doesn't make you feel like
there's nothing you can do about it
or powerless which is miserable and
like you had weight i had this
autoimmune disorder and it was like
i'm stuck with this forever there's
nothing i'm going to be able to do with
it like i'm going to be on medication
forever
and my joints are slowly going to just
disintegrate
like this is miserable um and
realizing you know and then you have the
medical system as well which says
yes you're right you are slowly
disintegrating and there's nothing you
can do about it it's genetic and you're
really unlucky
you're like well if the doctors are all
saying it you know since i'm a kid then
it's probably true
and having that switch where it's like
no you it's your responsibility only
like it's really only your
responsibility which is scary but it's
also incredibly freeing when you realize
you know maybe there is something i can
actually do about this
yeah the medical system looks more and
more like a shady auto mechanic to me
every day where it's like i went in for
a flat tire and now i need a new
carburetor or whatever it is and it's
like one pill to fix this and
and 14 more pills to handle the side
effects of that pill and each
and and then we get to the idea of like
end of life
is just all our counter space is filled
with prescription bottles and
you know we just got ailments we never
knew we could have
um i do think uh
quite a bit of the
stuff that we address and listen i say
that as a father to somebody who has
type 1 diabetes
and i'm thankful every day for her
insulin
and that there's a pharmaceutical
company that produces it
and charges us way too much money for it
unfortunately but
thank god it's there um so i'm not just
a
totally anti-that system but i do think
um quite a bit of this stuff
could be addressed with how we're eating
and what we're eating and what it's
doing to us and
i think that there's all kinds of things
like
imagine just you've talked about it the
host of medications you've been on
that you changed the way you ate
and now are not on like this is a
miraculous thing
yeah yeah it definitely is
okay what made you decide to take
responsibility for your health
it was really it was before i even was
thinking about it in terms of health
it was um this idea that i was
in love with a girl and for the first
time uh
thinking about the future with her there
had been
other instances where i was in
relationships short-term relationships
where uh
i just didn't care the the future didn't
matter like beyond the weekend
i wasn't thinking like what's my life
gonna be like and
with this person i wasn't ever having
thoughts like that and then
i was with this girl and i was like oh
my god i could have a
really nice life with this person
and um i could enjoy her company
forever like i don't think i'm gonna get
sick of this one you know uh
and and i don't want her to get sick of
me and what does that mean
and how do i how do i take charge of
that because
the direction i'm headed in there isn't
much future the future is like
day to day wondering if i'm going to
make it through the night
and not really giving a [ __ ] so suddenly
i gave a little bit of a [ __ ] suddenly
there was like a fight to
to survive there and have experiences
with her
like um going on a hike which is
something i
never wanted to do because it hurt and
it was not
comfortable and and it was really
looking at life
through that lens that got me to
to start to take responsibility for my
life and then it took a long time to
learn more and more that it was really
up to me
um to to be in charge of that and i say
that like
um i was i was constantly trying to put
the onus on the food
and i think even in in your situation i
still think it's you i don't think it's
the food and and in that i just mean
like
you know what uh
is gonna happen if you eat that thing so
you don't eat that thing and
for me it was more just like
i wanted it to be something it wasn't i
wanted it to not be my responsibility
for a long time i was taking
responsibility it was just like the
gradual shift of going from
things are being done to me to
i'm in charge of everything you know the
the day that i
literally woke up going like oh all of
this
everything is up to me all of it that
was the day where i was like oh i can do
anything i can
do anything i want i can have the
muscles i want i can have the cardio i
want
i can have the life i want and it's it's
all just entirely me
um that was a big big day for me and
that took a
long time of me still trying to put the
responsibility
into something else
that was amazing that was great that was
perfect
that's what i experienced as well it was
a mindset the first thing was a mindset
change
and it was really like i tried every way
that it was not my responsibility
and it nothing was working and it was
failing really quickly
yeah like my body was not was not
working really quickly and i was like
[ __ ]
there's nobody that's gonna do this
other than me yeah
and then as soon as i as soon as that
happened it wasn't as soon
but things started improving like you
know like this
in a really rocky way almost right then
yeah yeah i think uh i think it's very
it's a very difficult lesson to tell
somebody because un
until you actually have it until you see
it and what it is
it's it's like um telling somebody how
to ride a bike just ride you know what i
mean like
once you're going you're not gonna fall
down until you think you're gonna fall
down and then you fall down like this
kind of crazy thing
but then you get up on the bike you
start pedaling and you're like oh i
understand this
since i'm doing it um
and then the the formula i think to get
there
is small victories i think for me it was
small victories
i hope that's true for others um
i don't know what else to to i don't
know another way to kind of
help people understand the shift from
being um
things are happening to me to i am
making everything you know i i am the
the god of my story or whatever however
you want to see this
um but i i think it's i think it's a
really
a really neat thing and um it's so much
fun to watch
other people go through that